[Musik]
herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer ich
begrüße sie zu einer sendereihe die wir
auf ihre anregung hin gestaltet haben in
ihren briefen äußerten sie nicht nur die
bitte nach rezepten sondern sie möchten
gleichzeitig praktische ratschläge
hinweise und tipps rund um küche und
haushalt erhalten wir kommen natürlich
ihren wünschen nach und haben eine neue
folge wie schmeckt's gestaltet heute zu
der ddr tv sendung haushalts allerlei
praktisch serviert kurz ups und diese
folge dieser sendereihe erschien 1983 in
der ddr auf der unterhaltungs
applikations tik tok ist mir ein
ausschnitt dieser sendung vorgeschlagen
wurden es wurde der hubs flip serviert
und das ließ mich stutzig werden denn
die zubereitung und die zutaten klingen
ganz schön unappetitlich unter einem
geheimen decknamen bin ich dann auf die
hausseite youtube gestoßen wo es den
gesamten film zu schauen gab und seitdem
lässt mich die frage nicht los wie
schnecken rezepte aus einer tv sendung
aus der ddr aus dem jahre 1983 ich hoffe
sie sind nun mit von der partie und
wünsche ihnen viel spaß bei diesem neuen
film und dachten wahrscheinlich was für
ein tolles wortspiel das ist ne hubs mit
einem hub system und euch
sagen leute dieser herbst flippt er hat
mich wirklich wahnsinnig gemacht die
zutaten sind wirklich unfassbar gut und
ich muss einfach wissen wie es schmeckt
ganz kurz bevor wir mit diesem neuen wie
schmeckt's anfangen ich hab das gestern
gekauft und die haben vergessen diesen
clip ab zu machen ich bin durch die tür
gelaufen das hat gebebt und dann bin ich
sogar noch zurückgegangen habe gesagt
hey leute ich glaube da ist noch ein
clipper dran und dann hat er die tüte so
über ein gerät gehalten weil sie so
nicht alles gut und dann meine ich okay
bin nach hause habe das heute morgen
angezogen und der jetzt sieht einfach
aus als ob es gestohlen hätte in der
wunderbaren sendung haushalts allerlei
praktisch serviert machen sie nicht nur
den herbstblues sondern auch ein anderes
getränk und noch einen kuchen jetzt
fangen wir erstmal an mit dem hubs flip
und zwar ist das eine kreation von uns
der so genannte hubs club und die
zutaten für einen hartz iv lips sind
milch rotwein bier
richtig pfeffer und also wenn euch diese
zutaten nicht schon richtig lust auf
diesen habsburg machen dann weiß ich
auch nicht so meine zuschauer jetzt
können wir auch schon zur zubereitung
dafür brauchen wir erst mal ein glas
alles sträubt sich in mir dieses ding zu
machen alles
um
150 milliliter milch
als nächstes kommt der rotwein eine
halbe flasche es gibt besonders feind
gekannt wohlgeschmack armee sowie macht
sie da gar nicht rein yummy yummy yummy
yummy da kommt jetzt das helle bier wir
sagen eine flasche aber ich mache jetzt
eine halbe sein weil ich glaube es ist
ein ultra glas
an dem mit dem ps sparen sie auf jeden
fall nicht im regen sich wäre nicht wann
es wenn ich nicht vanessa wäre das
hasseröder wurde auch schon in der ddr
gebraut und ich glaube auch schon davor
apropos bier hier mit natürlich noch
mehr zum bibellesen das liter bier war
das einzige bier in der ddr was in der
dose hergestellt wurde also nur die
hatten eine dose abfüllung perfekt ich
wollte es aber keinen dosen bier rein
machen weil dann hätte ich glaub ich
wirklich gekotzt das ist wirklich das
fängt hier anrede pervers zu werden
gerade
spaß von denen das können julians als
nächstes sogar zu süßen wie man es mag
je nachdem wenn sie etwas süßer irgend
ein bisschen mehr als
ein ganzes
dann noch zur richtigen schärfe ein
bisschen pfeffer klar das passt ganz
wunderbar das ist unsere harte mischung
hier habe leider nie das handtuch und
nix gerät rg 28 aber dafür habe ich ein
anderes rührgerät
die richtige konsistenz ist da ich wenn
das getränk schaumig geworden ist
einmal für sie meine verehrten zuschauer
einen blick auf unseren blick ganz tolle
farbe ganz appetitlich also
wahrscheinlich haben es viele von euch
schon mit geschrieben aber jetzt noch
einmal hier könnt ihr es mit schreiben
und nun meine damen und herren stellen
wir uns wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmeckt dieser gottverdammte
hubs flip aus der sendung hab's
nicht mal der sieben schichten soll hat
mir so viel überwindung gekostet trost
leute
also ich muss nicht kotzen glaube es
gibt einen ganzen zucker
der rotwein kommt sehr gut durch das
bier schmeckt man auch das schmecke ich
lustigerweise nicht in zucker auch
schmeckt hat also mein bier gleichzeitig
mit rotwein trinken das könnt ihr euch
ja wahrscheinlich vorstellen empfehlen
würde ich jetzt nicht aber für eure
kleine ddr party ist bestimmt ein
witziges gadget okay ich mir jetzt aber
schon überrascht dass es nicht ganz so
widerlich ist
schmeckt schon nicht gut machen wir
weiter mit dem nächsten als nächstes
machen wir den feinschmecker drink und
dafür brauchen wir flammen und natürlich
die aus dem spreewald mehr weil die
waren ehemals ddr puderzucker joghurt
rum und ich weiß nicht ob sie in der ddr
damals rum gemacht haben ich habe hier
ein aus barbados zimt und eine bio
zitrone und so geht die zubereitung
eingelegte flammen waren in meiner
kindheit noch ein ding als ich in polen
war und mein opa seine selbst angelegten
pflaume präsentiert seitdem haben sie
eigentlich nicht mehr gegessen oder
getrunken
diesmal machen wir nur die halbe portion
in unseren praktischen behälter würden
wir unsere flaum hinein 300 gramm
puderzucker hast also beim reinpacken
sagt er 300 gramm und auf der liste
steht drei esslöffel machen wir drei es
klingt sehr viel da hat er sich vor
lauter aufregung wahrscheinlich
versprochen eine platte yoghurt wir
nehmen eine halbe flasche wird ein glas
rum obwohl die kombination pflaume und
warum ich weiß nicht kennt ich bin der
meinung das kommt eigentlich ganz gut so
wir machen mal hier zuschauer sofort
kann
eine messerspitze zimt
so abgeriebene zitronenschale so und nun
wird unsere leckere mixtur gemixt
das geht ganz fantastisch mit dem r b 28
es wird serviert
[Musik]
das ist ein feinschmecker dringt aber
jetzt hat auch eine ganz fantastische
idee aber jetzt kommt noch die abrundung
das i tüpfelchen das ist eine blaue auf
dieses getränk hier unser i-tüpfelchen
die flamme
kommt dann hat
und nun stellen uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt der
feinschmecker drink auf rang 19
moment
die man hier ist kein ein großes plus so
gut und fleisch schmeckt hat echt gut
zusammen und sind dazu auch in rom und
pflaumen schmecken auch gut zusammen
also was schmeckt gewöhnungsbedürftig
aber irgendwie nicht
wichtigste ist die flamme
ich sag mal so wenn ich bei einer ddr
mottoparty wäre und dieses getränk
bekommen würde ich nicht enttäuscht
auf zum nächsten
sollten sie unerwartet besuch bekommen
oh mein gott ich bekomme in einer halben
stunde spontanbesuch können sie schon in
einer halben stunde eine leckere quark
torte auf den tisch bringen und die
zutaten für diese quakt orte sind mehl
zucker und backpulver als erstes trennen
wir unsere eigelb vom eiweiß
3 1
3 esslöffel zucker gar kein problem wenn
es auch wirklich kreis löffel zucker
sind drei esslöffel mehl klar kein
problem und ein halbes päckchen
backpulver das ganze wird berührt klar
kein problem
dieser tag ist so krümelig für wir uns
immer um den eischnee nehme den drei
weisen
ja und den 1 stimme ist einfach mal in
unsere krümel reiten
dann noch mal mit dem 28
also das sieht schrecklich aus einer
fetten und verteilen klar und es kommt
da unsere war ganz ganz tolle masse und
es ist auch bestimmt genug für die
es aber ganz ehrlich bei ihm in der
sendung auch so komisch wenig aus er hat
dir ja dann einen kuchen vorbereitet
also ich bin gespannt wenn es jetzt
gleich bug bei mittlerer hitze für zehn
minuten was da so rauskommen
[Musik]
während der boden bebt haben wir für sie
einen vorbereitet cdu und später sieht
der kuchen eigentlich gar nicht mal so
schlecht aus deswegen flicken wir jetzt
so
und umdrehen
da gibt es dann ich habe wieder auf fels
klebe nicht mal so ein bisschen als
nächstes gehen wir auf die bestellseite
unseres vertrauens und besorgen uns
unseren tortenboden wir sehen uns dann
gleich wieder wenn es kommt zehn minuten
später haben wir für sie einen
vorbereitet ich weiß gar nicht woran es
liegt dass der so festgeklebt ist
dass nico die meter das eigentlich ist
dass es in der ddr so wenig sachen gab
und ich kann mir einfach alles jederzeit
sofort mir hin bestellen innerhalb von
zehn minuten und für unser quark gucken
topping brauchen wir magerquark und
schlagsahne und ganz wichtig
kaffeepulver bereiten ist jetzt mal zune
hierbei haushalts allerlei praktisch
serviert ja machen wir gute sachen okay
mein kollege drei bücher benutzt ich
benutze nur
eineinhalb dazu kommt ein natürlich muss
es wieder neu seien circa zwei bis drei
esslöffel zucker kein problem das ganze
wirkt gerührt alles klar dann ruhig
jetzt das ganze
auf den teig gegeben den mann nach dir
keine halben sachen gleich auf den teig
dann mehr drauf
[Musik]
theoretisch könnte man das jetzt noch
offenbarten machen wir aber nicht mögen
einmal ruhe darauf als abschluss ein
viertelliter schlagsahne das haben wir
auch schon vorbereitet ja wir haben hier
nichts vorbereitet
ja klar also jetzt kommt erstmal hier
drei liter sahne obendrauf wunderbar
genau so soll es aussehen
und obenauf als farb punkt und auch zur
abrundung des geschmacks etwas
kaffeepulver
mensch ist also möglich
was erwartet man von der kwag dort und
nun meine zuschauer stellen wir uns
wieder der allerwichtigsten frage wie
schmecken die cvag torte aus der sendung
es schmeckt sehr gut nach kaffee
also wenn dieses rohr einig wäre fände
ich das richtig richtig lecker
das steht sogar einigermaßen sit-in so
kleider schreibt mir aus welcher
komischen serie ich noch was nach machen
soll oder sendung aus der ddr oder aus
dem fernsehen oder aus 1910
[Musik]